Three,
two,
one,
boom.
And we're live with happened in Joe.
What's up Mike Thompson girls in the
house for man minutes here by to say hi.
I can't believe you've never had a cup
of coffee.
Never.
Do you want some know that that might
be.
That might be the most outrageous thing
about you is that you've never had
coffee your whole life.
Ever had coffee.
Now did you just tea,
never coffee.
No one ever offered you a cup of coffee.
He never went to starbucks?
No.
Fatigue with and donut.
Wow.
What about like when I was in Rehab,
you always got to go to starbucks
because the meetings right outside of
starbucks,
he always hang out at starbucks.
Right,
but never for coffee.
You didn't want to try it?
Never.
Hmm.
That is that.
How about like,
like girlfriends wives?
Like none of them ever drank coffee at
home.
I'm sure they have.
I never really,
my wife drinks it and you'd just
nothing.
No,
No.
Well,
I'm so addicted to drugs that,
did you think coffee?
It'd be nothing.
That's what I'm saying.
Yeah,
that's what I'm saying.
Like it doesn't make any sense.
When,
when did you first try any drugs?
Um,
kid and your kids?
What kind of Shit?
Smoking and drinking.
Right.
Then as I got older I tried to ask it.
How old were you when he first tried to
ask her?
11.
Wow.
Really Young.
Jesus man.
Wow,
that's really young.
Wow.
But when you were the champ,
when you were in your prime,
like when you,
when like when you beat Trevor Berbick
when you doing anything back then was
drinking a lot.
Drinking a lot.
Really?
Yeah.
That's amazing.
Well you go clean for camp or like if a
camp just for camp,
the camp outside once fights over and
say,
yeah,
you were the first guy that I ever used
as an example of a to break that old
myth that you can't have sex before
fights.
And I was like,
well that's out the window for sure.
Cause you,
you would talk about it all the time.
He'd be like,
yeah,
I'm pretty much yet
your logic made sense to you?
Like I don't want to think about it.
I don't want to be thinking about sex.
I'll just get it out of the way.
Yeah.
And there's over what do,
you don't have to do it.
You have fuel for the next six weeks and
it's going to fight.
Do you think that was a myth that it
made you weak?
Yeah,
I think it's a myth.
Yeah.
It doesn't seem to make sense.
It seems odd.
Yeah.
And then whenever the spy you more so
than the synagogue too,
I would think they said that the
Olympic,
uh,
you know where the athletes stay,
it's just like fuck fest.
Oh yeah.
They had the boy and the girl if the
thing facility,
yeah.
We also probably want to leave.
You ate some anxiety,
anxiety,
freaking out.
You're at the Olympics,
you know,
you're 18 years old and everyone's in
amazing shape.
Dresses out.
Stressed out.
Yeah.
When you were,
when you were first coming up and when
you were first,
uh,
we,
you like when you were
a kid,
dynamite on sports illustrated.
I'll never forget that man.
That was a,
that your era from like,
you know,
the 80s,
the late eighties,
that error,
like it was a big part of my youth.
You know,
like,
yeah man,
you being the chant.
It was like,
it was a change of things because when
Larry Holmes was the champ,
as a boxing fan,
I loved Larry Holmes.
Like there's that cover.
You were 19 years old,
right?
It's nuts.
When Larry Holmes was the champ as a
boxing fan,
why you still got that stuff,
man.
You can still get those sports
illustrated.
It's the Internet.
You can find it on the Internet.
That's how Jamie got it.
Um,
I had that sports illustrated,
but when Larry Holmes was a,
a champ,
as a boxing fan,
I appreciated him.
I knew he was a great fighter.
I,
you know,
we would get together with friends and
watch like the,
the,
the Michael spinks fight with Larry
Holmes.
When spinks beat him for the title.
It was a big deal,
but it wasn't a big deal.
Culturally.
Yeah.
People didn't care as much.
But then you came around and when you
came around,
all this sudden everybody's watching
heavyweight boxing.
Heavyweight boxing wasn't,
it wasn't boring again.
It was the,
the most crazy exciting thing in sports.
When your fights would go on,
it would be about,
should I pay for this cause how long is
this going to last?
Like dad never.
We had people telling me about that
come,
they all chipped in and took a fight on
the phone.
I know.
Think about it like that,
you know,
sometimes
when it comes from out
realization of the situation,
I forget that I'm that guy.
I forget that train that hard and I
became a fighter and stuff.
Yeah,
that's what I was going to ask you.
Like d does it seem like a dream?
Yeah,
pretty much like a blur
because I,
I couldn't imagine what it would be like
to be 19 years old,
20 years old at that fucking famous.
It was a trip.
Who,
who can handle that is then,
can anybody handle that?
No.
It was a trip,
but it was just what to mind,
you know,
that was his blueprints and make me
teenage superstar.
Did he give you advice on how to handle
pressure and fame and
Oh,
depression,
everything,
but you know.
MMM.
It,
there's really no um,
ingredients.
We'll have a handle thing,
you know what I mean?
Um,
we have to see what,
what I'm department of fame is your
problem and we have to work on that
issue from there.
But no ones knows how to conduct
themselves under that kind of pressure.
No,
the level of fame too,
it's like there's so many,
you realize there's so many levels of
fame and then Mike's is still just
extraordinary where like people,
people walk away from their job,
like an airport.
They're supposed to be at the cash
register and they run out,
you know,
they leave their job to go say hi,
that's not,
you know,
most of the time I'd be like,
oh,
that's who that person is.
It's a totally thing.
Or where does that
pretty weird
confidently get used to this device to
be willing to like get the fuck away
from me,
man,
when you're doing creep,
I never knew how to conduct myself.
I might come in and take a picture,
take a picture of my kid,
take a picture here,
take a picture of it.
I love this and that.
And I'm like,
Whoa,
dude,
cool out.
You know what I mean?
But now,
you know,
I understand this is just what it is.
It is what it is and you're not going to
be able to stop it.
Yeah.
I've seen you at the UFC before.
You're very calm around people on people
grabbing at,
you want to take pictures.
He just,
just relax.
You got to see is awesome cause
everybody's nuts.
Yeah.
That's a,
it's a,
it's definitely a wild environment.
What do you think of beeps going to do
now?
But I think who could be,
um,
while he does whatever the fuck he wants
to do,
that's where I think,
I think that goes probably the best
lightweight of all time.
He's a monster credible.
He,
um,
I think he's probably gonna have some
fights at 170 pounds eventually,
if I'd imagine at 155.
There's,
you know,
there's good fights for him.
Tony Ferguson's a great fight for him.
Um,
uh,
really interested in seeing that.
Uh,
I'm really interested in seeing him
going up a really interesting to see him
fight at 170 pounds from the fight.
Well,
first of all,
tyron Woodley,
who was the champ at 170 that that would
be an insane fight.
George St Pierre.
If he decided to come back and make a
big super fight,
that would be an insane fight.
I think 170 has a lot of opportunities
for them,
but I think 155 does too.
They just have to figure out who's going
to fight him.
He's an international superstar now.
You know,
could be,
especially the way he smashed connor
connor.
Such a superstar ready that the way it
could be one and did it so dominant.
I think he's,
I think he's through the roof now.
I think when people,
when he comes back and people see the
paper view numbers of his fights are
going to realize how huge this guy is
because he's so interesting.
He's very humble,
very,
very.
He's very polite,
very well spoken and very religious guy.
Lives with his family,
lives with his parents,
his family,
I believe.
I hope I'm not speaking out of school.
I believe that's true.
And obviously it doesn't have to for
money and he's rich as shit now,
but he's just a monster.
The best,
best grappler I've ever seen inside the
155 pound division.
He just smashes people.
He's thinking about Jon Jones.
What?
W in what way?
And it was still his skill.
He's phenomenal.
Incredible.
The best ever it using distance.
He knows distance better than anybody.
He's a master at knowing when he can hit
you and you can't hit him with watching
them fight.
You know what I mean?
He's been fighting as much anymore.
He's back.
He just one,
just one the title again,
just fun.
Alexander Gustafson.
Yeah.
A couple of weeks ago.
For Bacon Peyto it was Daniel Cormier,
Aka relinquish his title and it was
like,
it's weird,
right?
Like call me a is the champ because Jon
Jones tested positive for something.
So they stripped him and then call me a,
became the champ.
It's,
uh,
you know,
I think they'll probably fight again
whether they fight again and heavyweight
or light heavy.
Really?
Yeah.
I core main Jon Jones
and Cormier,
he wants to keep going,
but he says he wants to retire soon.
He's 40,
you know?
Yeah.
It feel looks good.
He looks great.
Especially at heavyweight and
heavyweight.
He's,
he doesn't have to cut weight.
He's got so much strength and s two so
agile,
he's such a unbelievable wrestler too.
I mean his wrestling skill,
his skill level and understanding of
wrestling so high,
so above most p anybody find out finally
doing John Jones?
He dominated.
Yeah.
That's how good John Is.
John's dad.
Good.
He's that.
I mean,
it just sucks that he's had so many
controversies in his life,
but I'm hoping he puts all that shit
behind him.
Have you ever spoken with him about
that?
Never been his personal life and live
when we met before and talk.
But you're a guy who's gone.
I mean,
when you went through legal problems
yourself,
you,
you overcame,
you came out of it.
On the other hand,
I think would think a guy like him could
benefit a lot from,
but it's just so difficult and you're
throwing fucking,
did they have to go through something
like that,
you know?
Do you think so?
Yeah.
[inaudible] you know,
cause sometimes people,
um,
they will survive situations like that
because they're so wild and they're
having a good time too much in the party
and the champ,
it has to have to come to an end.
That stuff,
if you don't bring it to the next club,
bring it could come to his own and it
might not like that way then.
Yeah.
So you think for a guy like him,
maybe getting in trouble was a good
thing if only if you learn from
experiences like that.
You know,
I think I was just a wild guy.
I was really a wild guy.
I look at myself now and I feel myself
when I spent those trips and those psych
wards and thought that,
what was that all about?
What,
what's wrong with me back then,
you know?
Yeah.
And I must say I was really disturbed
back then.
But you're somebody who got to the point
where you got like,
it's really fascinating because I know
you're not,
you're a public figure.
So I,
you know,
I've been able to watch you my whole
life.
You went through all that stuff and then
you got to this point where you are very
self reflective and you look at,
you are able to comment on it.
I don't think most,
I mean most people regardless of whether
they're famous or not,
just still don't get to that point where
they're able to look back and examine
who they were and doing wild shit and
with ruth
honesty.
Yeah.
That's what's so great reflecting itself
to discover who you really are.
Yeah.
When you're 20 years old and all of a
sudden you're the heavyweight champion
of the world and just a few years ago
you were poor and now all of a sudden
you're the king of the world.
That's really crazy.
You're not so really crave that.
I was,
I was unable to handle it.
I wasn't expecting that.
That was a really sucker punch right
there and the real sucker punch.
Right?
Yeah.
I wasn't ready for that one.
Charlie Murphy told us a story and it's
animated.
It's on youtube now of you and him
coming over your house in a limousine
and you had a,
it was a lion or a tiger.
Tiger.
He must though the line for it the way.
Yeah,
the tiger.
It is one of the craziest fucking
stories.
I always win.
So for people that don't know,
I got to hang out with you at one of my
shows one time and it was a great,
I had the best time talking about
everything.
What made you think you could get a
tiger?
Like how did that even happen?
Hey,
I'm in.
Um,
and so,
um,
I'm in prison at the time,
so I'm in prison.
I'm talking to my car dealer at the time
and he has this,
he has some caused the belonged to a
friend of mine that's supposed to friend
of ours and he's discussing the fee
doesn't pay for these cars.
I'm to sell these cars to somebody and
get some horses and stuff.
I said,
well he can get a horses.
Horses are for card.
Cause I had a lot of cards.
I said I probably get some horses.
Yeah man,
you get,
you get cool goods.
Lions,
tigers.
I love this guy.
Got exactly what I see you do.
Can you get me some tigers?
Yeah.
And the guy told me and the guy from,
imagine how cool that would be be cause
I had a bunch of fans because magnetic
man,
he'd be in the afternoon or for Rami.
You have a tiger right next to you,
man.
And
I'm saying to myself why that would be
cool.
Right after he had gave me some cousin
and then I came home,
I had those cubs.
Right.
They're waiting for me.
So you raised them as cubs?
Yeah,
because that's,
that's how you work.
Because I would see footage of you like
fucking smacking them around and jumping
on one of your tires.
And I was like,
Holy Shit.
And I had my third baby and their
mother,
the mother babies.
Now she never gets,
this is a crazy picture.
You and your underwear with a tiger on a
chain that is,
that is one of the,
that's that's you at peak.
Crazy.
Yeah,
and thing.
Yeah.
What was going through my mind.
No,
it made me think about my friends and
Mike.
You can get from our from animal.
Nothing really are serious.
I'm going to give him a whole effort.
Everybody does it though.
So one of the things about,
uh,
with,
what's his face from narcos?
Pablo Escobar,
he got like a fucking zoo.
I had a whole crazy zoo.
They all do it.
Once you get like that rich,
you're like,
just get some animals,
some animals
and they throw people in there with the
Lions and tigers.
Real common thing that is super rich
people.
They start getting lunch and shit.
Jacqueline had all that stuff.
That's right.
Michael Jackson.
Yeah.
They had like a zoo in his backyard.
He had weird shit.
Like weird birds.
Yeah.
I don't think it may be at a monkey or
something.
He did have weird shit.
Nothing dangerous day before the playboy
mansion.
This is at the end of his career.
That was like whoa.
The thing years ago or something.
It was pretty awesome.
Yeah.
That guy,
man.
What a life.
He loved.
He'll
pajamas balls.
When you say 80 and shit,
they're like,
oh no.
Eighties deep into his eighties nineties
yeah.
He really,
here's the thing that dude lived the
lifestyle he was talking about.
You know a lot of people talk shit.
Yeah,
you don't really do that.
He was really doing it,
I thought would be dark or fucking dog.
You you blue wall.
That's just too much.
Yeah.
Much one other thing.
I got it cause I got to run and I wanted
that I hadn't had gone man,
I gotta go,
I gotta go meet the wife Man.
I do it.
They'll do it.
I read one time cause oh wait.
So for people that know I,
I met Mike on a flight and it was a
surreal experience,
you know,
like from,
from being a kid and thinking like this
is superman.
That's what I thought I was a kid.
It's just,
you know what I mean?
Like seeing those when you see it as a
kid too,
I think it's different.
Like you're just like,
whoa,
that is so nuts.
Like these 11 second knock out
periodically.
Even to this day,
people come up to me and talk about the
experience that they feel,
how many talked about meeting me and
through that true
all it takes honestly,
mostly stories that true.
Yeah,
mostly stories.
And it was a,
it was a surreal experience.
And,
and you know,
we spoke on the plane and then like when
I thought we were done talking,
you know,
I face forward and then he came back and
like tapped me on the shoulder.
I was like,
Oh shit.
Like Mike's talking to me,
I'm down here like the seatbelt,
seatbelt it in.
But then we land and he was like,
Oh,
where's your show?
And,
and,
and I go,
oh,
it's here.
I gave him the number,
never expect to hear,
hits me up the next day.
And he's like,
we're coming to your show.
And I was like,
oh my God.
And I really did say like,
I'm amazed that you're coming.
And he said,
it's all love.
And I just said,
I love you because I didn't know how to
what to say.
And then that was good.
He was like,
cool.
He's like,
all right,
man.
And
I,
I remember I called the,
uh,
the Pittsburgh improv manager and I go,
hey man,
I just go,
you're not gonna believe this,
but Tyson is coming to the fight
tonight.
And he goes,
Mike Tyson,
I go,
no fucking Tyson chicken.
Yeah,
Mike Tyson is coming tonight.
He was like,
I'll corridor off a whole thing.
And you know,
and I didn't know he was at the show
because the show had already started and
I didn't see him arrive.
When we go back to the green after the
show,
I walk offstage and he grabs me and he
goes,
let's go to the green room.
So he took me to my green room,
right?
Like he would like,
and I was like,
fuck.
Yeah.
And we hung out in that green room over
an hour and just shooting the shit and
talking.
And when I forgot,
like if at the time had passed,
I opened the door,
the entire staff,
entire staff is lined up at the door to
meet him.
Like that's the effect that he has on
the group.
You know,
like they're waiting in a line for an
hour outside of the green room and like,
you know,
we talked about boxing about life.
It was,
it was fascinating.
One of the things I really appreciated
about you as a fighter was like,
that you really knew that you were
putting on a show.
So that,
that's something that I feel like I
miss.
You know,
there's,
there's no one that put on the show the
way you did.
Like you knew that people bought tickets
and paid for the paper view.
Um,
and then it,
you know,
it's still like one of my great
memories,
man.
It was a thrill to meet you.
Um,
so I just wanted to stop by and say hi
and I was like,
you're wrapping up,
ramping it up.
Yeah.
He has to go.
Oh,
by the way,
did you buy seven Bentley's that were
the same color?
No,
but I bought it around seven Bentley's
before damn near Rolls Royces.
I wanted to ask you,
you did give away one when you crashed
it,
right.
Gotten,
um,
I was married at the time,
the robin givens,
and we were in,
um,
fast food,
January,
order the food,
and she went in my pocket,
I guess to get some money out my pocket
to pay for it.
And she's had some fun.
Condoms came out and she was mad.
So she got in the car and then boom,
she crashed the car into another car
that was just parked here.
Boom.
And she hit somebody and she hurt their
arm.
And then,
um,
the cops came and so the cops came into
capsule or saying,
Hey,
what happened here?
Right.
And,
um,
I was afraid of they were arrest me or,
and so I said,
well,
nothing happened,
officer.
Um,
nothing.
He said the guy was,
and it was the guy with a broken on my
thing,
you know,
so why don't you just take the car,
you deserve it because you've been
through doing a lot.
Cause I didn't want to get rent,
I didn't have rights as anything and I
didn't want my wife to get in trouble.
If you want to just take it,
you know,
it wasn't that it was around 230 at the
time,
so why don't you just take it?
It'd be okay.
And the guy said,
hey,
don't tell me that.
And then once he said that,
I said got him,
I got him.
Nothing man taking me through this man,
you deserve this.
Take it.
And they took it out.
But before that,
the guy from guy arm was broken and he,
I gave him my money as her take the
money and then he came back to the
police,
my army.
But it kept him.
Now he can get away from,
I'm not going to tell you to get away
from me no more because he didn't want
to mess this dealer with this car.
Cause the guy,
he's not going to get this car.
That's a little coffee.
Don't fucking come near me again.
That hit me.
Larry Guy,
he's backed off and I go,
hey man,
I feel it.
And I took off my work.
I didn't want us to get in trouble,
but they made him give away the car.
Right.
They made it real.
He could cause I went back to my office.
I said,
give me my fucking car back.
Going to that.
Yeah,
he got fired.
He probably hearing his name.
I'm going to get that back to the title.
I wanted my Indian giver one of my car.
Oh No.
Oh Man.
Mike Tyson calls you up and says,
give me my fucking car,
man.
Like,
Shit.
It's outside,
man.
I got to lift those.
I take it.
You guys know I embarked on the
marijuana.
Been that says it's been this way.
This is this a beautiful box.
Thank you so much.
Awesome.
Thank you Ma'am for accepted my
pleasure.
That's a cool ass box,
man.
Tight him ranch is going to be open a
pretty surely.
You guys have too.
I saw that.
I mean this is a big deal.
I mean this place is gigantic state.
It's,
it's in California.
Yeah.
They're,
they're setting up like a resort.
Really could be the best facility in the
world,
man.
It's going to be on it.
Feel handcuff an eco long
lake.
Wow.
Yeah,
but you could go like that's going to be
camping glamping like glamping.
Glamorous camping.
Glamorous.
Very glamorous.
Yeah.
Had some tigers and shit for some wild
bill Hickman with discussing that too.
Where are those times?
I had him for like 14 years,
so I had to get rid of or you know what
I mean?
What do you do when you want to get rid
of a tie?
A sanctuary and fucking,
I got to run.
I love you.
I love you too,
buddy.
Look better cannabis dude.
There it is.
Yeah.
Congrats on that man.
That looks down.
Oh often man.
Fuck excited about this stuff.
This is,
I love him barking.
Let us cannabis.
They had a message,
so awesome.
Yeah.
You,
you seem to be really enjoying this when
you're talking to your partners out
there.
You're,
you're having a good time with this.
Oh Man.
I never thought in a million years I'd
be able to do this and legalize.
Yeah.
When did you start like regularly
smoking weed?
Um,
since I was like 10 years old the whole
time we were fighting,
you were regular smoking weed.
Well,
you know,
when you're a kid,
your mother gives you liquor and
marijuana for him.
He could think that you're going to go
to sleep or something.
Yeah.
Really?
That never happened in my house.
Never be.
Yeah,
I ain't no mother was alcoholic.
That's,
that's harsh liquor and marijuana.
See if you go to sleep.
Yeah.
It didn't work.
I don't think so.
Do you,
uh,
what,
what benefits you get out of marijuana?
Like what does it do for you?
Hey Man.
Um,
if I didn't have a bad day,
yeah.
I'm really Moody Guy Without it
and it just smooths me out.
So they'll take,
I'm a whole different person.
I'm really on top of my game.
I'm boiling.
Yeah.
I feel the same way sometimes it makes
me nicer.
Yeah.
Calms me down.
Do you,
um,
do you kind of like who I am when I
smoke?
You know what I mean?
When I'm,
when I weed,
I don't sometime like who I am
sometimes.
That's just the real something.
Yeah.
I don't like that guy.
Want to get away from that guy.
Well,
you know,
I was talking to Michael Irvin once,
he was explaining it to me that when
children grow up in high stress
environments that their genes are wired
to,
to have a propensity towards violence,
that if they're normal,
if it's normal,
if it's around them all the time when
they're,
when they're growing up and when they're
in the womb.
Yeah,
I agree.
When their mothers under extreme stress,
if they live in a bad neighborhood and
it's,
it's hard for some people like yourself
that did grow up in an environment like
that to ever reached where you're at
right now.
Just a place of peace.
And if you can do that through marijuana
or whatever it is,
Yoga,
meditation,
whatever,
whatever you do to get there,
like we should be happy that you could
get there.
That's what we want.
I am so grateful that um,
I embarked on this,
you know,
I've never been a person to this,
its magnitude at this kind of
relaxation.
Are you enjoying my time with you?
I was very uptight.
It and anytime I was with very
uncomfortable with myself.
Did you feel any better after you worked
out when you were young like that?
Absolutely.
But my workout,
you know what,
I'm the best thing ever happened to me
that we tied from Barclays because of me
working out and meagan that was so
intense with it.
My whole,
my whole objective was hurting people
and one beat a Beth and my ego took over
and I'm like,
Tyson,
I'm the best to ever live and all this
bullshit.
And um,
dealing with my partner,
Rob Hickman,
I happened to embark on this,
um,
come across this thing called the toad
and he,
you familiar with the toe?
Yeah.
Well you're talking about it's five
methoxy dominance that fit right there.
Yeah.
And I came across that and I smoked
this,
um,
I don't know this medicine,
drug,
wherever you want to call it.
And,
and um,
I've never been the same.
I look at life different.
I look at people differently and um,
that you experienced that can't even
express really,
it's almost like dying and being real
reborn.
Yeah.
I had
the exact same experience.
That's what it felt like to me too.
Like you stop existing,
the five methoxy is,
uh,
there's two coming with the deal with
that.
What the Hell's going on here?
Five minutes is produced by your brain,
but what it is is,
uh,
it's dmt with an oxygen molecule
attached to it to so regular DMT is n n
dimethyltryptamine and then five methoxy
dimethyltryptamine dmt with like a very,
there's a very subtle change to the
molecule.
And that subtle change for some reason
takes away the visuals you've done
regular dmt to,
right.
Yes.
Regular DMT is rich with visuals.
Very strained,
bright,
colorful,
impossible.
Described visuals.
Yeah.
If,
um,
if inconceivable,
inconceivable is best with here
viewable.
But I tried to explain it to some
people,
my wife and I use,
it's just,
I don't have the words to explain it.
That's exactly what I would say.
I've done a terrible job explaining it
to everybody.
Every time I've tried it just doesn't
work.
Um,
with the,
all those things,
they,
they give you perspective almost like
you're dying.
You have your,
your submissive,
you're humble,
you know what I mean?
You're vulnerable,
but you're invincible still in awe,
you know?
It's just that weird feeling,
but you feel like you're part of the
universe when you're,
you're separate from your ego.
You realize this whole thing.
You're a part of this whole thing and
this whole thing is unstoppable.
It's just,
it's a gigantic,
huge,
all encompassing,
almost like a living thing.
I know,
John,
this is where I also realize too,
I have to go into that experience.
You realize how insignificant you are
sometimes without your ego.
Yes.
You know you made,
why are you not really much that you
really thought you were?
Yeah,
you are and you aren't.
Obviously you are in everyday life.
I mean,
you go places,
you have a dramatic effect on people.
You mean a lot.
He mean a lot to those people that you
run into.
You mean a lot to the people that you
love and that love you,
but we all do and when the no one,
Stan,
no,
it's all,
it's all relative.
No one,
no one has a replaceable,
but everyone is special to someone or
something and at least to themselves,
but we're all the same.
We're all part of this weird,
crazy,
gigantic organism.
That's the human race,
you know,
thought that you said it.
My mental cus d'amato hit objective with
the think of nothing.
You're nothing.
Nothing is nothing but the objective,
the job.
And that was the psychological warfare.
You know,
nothing matters.
You're nothing,
nothing.
My only thing that matters is the
objective and getting to accomplishing
that objective by going to these methods
of boxing.
Do you ever stop and think about how
fortunate was you ran into that guy?
Listen,
till this day,
I really don't understand that though.
How did this happen?
Because so many lives and by the time I
was born,
he was 66 years old by the time I was
born.
Yeah.
Crazy.
So many people could,
you know,
can't even explain it.
It's a magnificent individual.
He was an amazing guy,
amazing part of boxing and uh,
uh,
with uh,
unprecedented grasp of the mindset
required for combat sports.
That was the thing that,
that always really stood out about him.
Like he was a guy that was so,
he was so well versed in the mindset
that would listen to his,
his speeches,
that he would talk when he would talk
about you and he would talk about
boxing.
We talk about fear and about fear can be
like a fire can cook your food,
your food,
or it can burn your house down and you
have to,
you have to control it.
And when he would describe it like it
would,
it would be so enlightening.
He was such a man of wisdom that when he
would describe things,
they would sink in.
They would,
they would,
somebody could say the same thing,
but the w w with him,
he had so much
life.
He was so many,
half of the psychiatry through the dock
to the father,
the mother,
you know,
he was just all around that individual.
Yeah.
And with the,
an amazing knowledge of boxing.
And for guy like you,
it was almost like it was
Dane.
And I thought all we filled with meant
for me to meet this guy because I had no
way.
In a million years.
Everybody say,
no way.
You're gonna be champion too small.
Yeah.
The two,
sure.
No Way.
These guys are too big for you.
He says this is the greatest fight ever
lived.
This and that.
The only thing is about me,
I'm like,
Oh God,
this guy's just swooped me up.
I never thought I could achieve what he
was saying and things he was saying was
just so,
um,
gigantic in my eye that,
yeah.
Yeah.
I mean
when it all happened and it turned out
that he was true and you have to absorb
all this when you're 20 years old,
you know,
it's,
I always say this about Justin Bieber
and I don't think Justin bieber nearly
had to deal with what you had to deal
with your,
your experience with so much crazier
because you were not just an incredibly
famous guy.
You were the baddest man on the planet.
So there was like an aura to you.
Everywhere you went,
people wanted to see you.
You know,
50 year old men don't give a fuck about
Justin bieber.
You know,
no disrespect.
He's a great guy,
a great singer,
but it's not.
He's like young girls for young girls
like guys,
unbelievably famous,
but he's,
he's been famous since he was a little
kid.
I'm like,
how when people hear about them going
right?
Amazing.
When people hear about him going insane,
I'm like,
of course he's going insane.
You have no idea what it would be like
to be him.
It'll be 17 years old and girls
literally trying to break into his house
to throw a pussy.
Adam did coming
down.
Chimneys,
they're flying in on parishes are doing
anything they can.
They just want to be around them and you
want him to be normal.
Poor guy.
No one can handle that.
What kind of music you're listening to?
I listen to everything that I do.
I listen to.
I was in a lot of classic rock for
whatever reason.
But uh,
I've been listening to a lot of Kanye
West over the last few weeks.
Tell me what he talking about.
Kanye.
Yeah,
well he's talking about a lot of crazy
shit he's taught.
He actually talked about dmt in one of
his recent songs.
Think he did that before.
I think he did.
Oh Man.
Well I know he's friends with kid cuddie
kid cut.
He'd been in here and kid cut.
He's had some psychedelic experiences.
Yeah.
Once you go to is just,
um,
you didn't want to do nothing else
again.
Well,
it puts it all in the perspective.
It lets you see that,
uh,
as much as this thing seems to be
important is all temporary and you're a
part of forever and it also allows you
to become comfortable with death.
Yeah.
You know who said that?
Larry Hagman remember that Guy Dallas Jr
Salad?
He did an interview with CNN and I dream
of Jeannie as well.
Yeah,
that's right.
He sprung it on him on CNN.
Once he was talking about how he did
acid,
he took a big dose acid and he's never
worried about death ever again.
That it just alleviated his,
his worry about passing on as,
wow.
This if that could,
I felt the same way.
I feel I haven't doesn't matter anymore.
Yeah.
I think dnt even more specifically
because they think,
yeah,
what that does fake the mine that way.
What causes the effect of mine that way
they don't know.
They didn't mean Gig visioning,
visualize everything.
Um,
they don't totally know.
They know that your brain makes it.
They know that your body makes it,
they should say and they know that it's
produced in your liver and their lungs
and there's some evidence now cause they
found it in rats,
that the pineal gland produces it,
which is like,
that's the third eye of eastern
mysticism that Glenn actually in rats,
they've proven produces dmt and they
think it does so on people too.
You know,
once I did,
I wanted to do it again and again and
again.
And if they shouldn't do too much,
my wife with me,
I got to,
you know,
grasp what's going on here.
Why am I feeling,
it's like why?
Why did this in a weird way,
like humbled you?
I don't think you should listen to the
people say you shouldn't,
you know too much.
I think you should do it as much as you
want.
I thought I agree with too.
Yeah,
I agree.
You could handle it.
If you can handle being like Tyson,
you can handle doing dmt issues,
emt.
Yeah,
that's what I think I'm going,
I'm like,
I'm going in that direction.
Well,
I mean it's not something you just do
all day everyday,
but you can learn a lot from it.
It's the,
and it's,
it's very beneficial and very strange
that it's illegal.
You know that it's illegal.
Yeah.
Notice that Terence Mckenna had a joke
about it because your body's making it
so everybody's holding,
we all have it.
You know,
it's illegal,
but it's like making blooded legal.
Everybody has.
And then why would he go to scenario
deadly when they find these tolls?
Yeah.
I've never experienced it from the toad
of owning a television where the way
they extracted grab them and they buses
pimples and the busing on the class a
marrow and then take it off and he let
it harden.
Yeah.
They,
they let it dry in the summer,
scrape it off with the razor blade.
I've only had it synthetically made in a
laboratory.
You smelled a buy it online.
Used to be able to buy like a fucking
can of it,
like this big enough to get like a whole
state high.
She's just buy it online.
It was totally legal.
Credible.
Yeah.
It's weird.
It's bizarre.
That is illegal.
Well,
they would say not for human consumption
and,
but I don't know.
What the fuck are you doing with it if
you're not using it for human
consumption,
but you,
you used to be able to buy it.
I've never felt anything like that
before.
No.
Nothing like that makes me not want to
do anything.
Nothing else can supersede that.
How long ago did it happen?
I don't know.
Around two months ago.
Yeah.
Did you write down what happened after
it happened or did you record it?
No,
I will shut that.
Yeah,
we should that.
me too.
If you'd like,
it goes away like a dream.
Right.
And comes off,
you know,
you're,
you're so scared.
You know stuff,
stuff like that.
Like,
no,
no.
Hey,
I want this to stop now.
And the guy was like,
hey,
you're on the ride.
And I'm like,
no,
no.
I love it.
I love you.
Yeah.
I love everybody.
Yeah,
so spassed out.
Yeah.
Did you have a hard time letting go at
the beginning of fighting me?
I don't think stop wanting to stop now.
Just jump.
Stop the shit now.
Stopping.
The guy was like,
hey,
the show.
I'm like,
I can do it.
Got to go for the ride,
dude.
And it was like,
whoa man.
Fuck,
I'm dying.
Things are going in my film theme,
the Aztec things.
I'm being told I'm going to seeing weird
animal.
The thing that you're flying,
it's just,
it's like another chamber.
It's boom flashing food and he'd gone to
take a rocker.
You taking off foom.
Yeah.
It's beyond your imagination.
DEF is inconceivable.
Can't even explain it to no one.
Well,
I'm hoping
that they,
they start with psilocybin because a,
I know maps there.
They're doing some great work with that.
Trying to get these things legalize
especially they're doing mtma studies
with veterans and people with Ptsd and
they're having great results.
They're moving in the civil side bend.
They would love to get silicide been
legal and it's up for ballot.
I think it was in Oregon.
Is that where it is?
It's up for,
I think Oregon is up for legalization
this year and it may be eventually in
California as well.
They may hate him.
Go do it.
It should be legal.
It doesn't kill anybody.
It should be,
it's not a bad thing if they regulate
it,
if they make it for therapeutic use and
just set up centers where experts can
show,
but they shouldn't make it prohibitive
for people to own it or even grow their
own.
It's not a bad idea to set up places
where people can do it.
Under a professionals care,
a showman's care.
Physicians Care,
that's a good idea,
but making it illegal is a bad idea
because it helps a lot of people,
you know,
people think of it as a party drug.
They think you're going to do mushrooms
and freak out and go fucking run around
naked and La was do mushrooms.
I love mushrooms.
Yeah,
well psilocybin and DMT or very closely
related chemically.
All those really potent psychedelic
drugs are very closely related.
They all break down in,
in some similar path inside your brain
and,
and give you
that,
that weird
ego dissolving experience.
Yeah.
That's one thing.
Most of the drugs you do it,
most of them.
Um,
Eagle enhancing,
right?
Like coke.
Yeah.
He likes some of the baddest mother and
he had gone and yeah.
You know,
you've never had coffee.
I've never had coke.
Never,
never.
Oh Man.
No.
You didn't miss out as nothing,
man.
Yeah.
That one I ducked when I was in high
school.
My friend's cousin used to sell it and
he,
he wasted away to nothing.
Knew him and his girlfriend would hang
out in the attic and never come out.
They would just sell coke and watch TV.
It was bad.
Like it was like a vampire bit him.
Aw Man.
He came up once you get in that kind of
vicious cycle.
It's a wrap.
Yeah.
So I ducked it.
Adopted early,
never did coke man was the first time he
did coke.
I Dunno,
it was kid 11,
12.
I got involved with drug early in life.
Wow.
That's crazy.
Uh,
1112.
Yeah.
I was still living in Brownsville,
Brooklyn when I first did cocaine.
Wow.
That's a crazy,
listen,
I would never let my children have a 10
year old daughter and eight year olds.
I would never let them look.
The life that I live,
I will hate thousand away fight for her
to live with and be in an environment
that I grew up in.
Yeah,
of course.
Well,
you know,
you have the benefit of having gone
through it.
You know?
No one else could ever understand how,
how,
how difficult any of your life must've
been for you.
It's gotta be one of the harder things
when,
when you did that documentary to amazing
documentary,
when you're very honest,
you're very honest and you're very open
about all your experiences.
And the one thing I took away after
that,
like no one can understand.
You could,
you could hear a guy talk like this.
I could hear you say these things.
I could see the videos of your fights to
see the videos,
your experience,
but to understand the life that you
lived,
it's impossible to,
it's just a guess.
It's like a guest.
For someone like me from the outside,
it's just really interested in it.
Look,
I think about this young kid,
Brooklyn,
and you come to the cuff though tomorrow
at 1312 you know,
and I'll something all of a sudden have
a low self esteem.
This guy gives me this big fucking ego,
you know what I mean?
I live by the,
you know,
I live by the rules of that ego and
that's,
and I have accomplished so much in a
dominator ego.
Yeah,
you're,
you're set.
Oh,
about destroying people.
Yeah.
Just anybody.
It could be a lawyer,
200 pounds.
I'm staring you down.
It's just weird environment up that way,
you know,
cause we have people,
we try to avoid fights,
you know what I mean?
Right.
From my instincts,
we avoid fights for all our lives and
just to be able to see what you do.
Like you UFC guy,
you're a fighter.
This is what you do for a job,
a lifestyle.
That's pretty bizarre.
You were getting positive reinforcement
from thinking like that for the first
time in your life.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
I never felt like that before.
We like taking up a big drug.
Elution has boomi.
It felt like get a man and then
everybody's telling you you're great.
Yeah.
You know,
for the first time in your life,
never understood that.
And you know what else customer I used
to do with me,
he used to take me to a hypnotist.
He was the hitting detention as well.
Yeah.
They used to go in the
hypnotist motions.
What kind of Shit did they make you?
Do you know how they do it?
Yes.
You relax,
you go under,
you totally focus on blackness.
Nothing that's right.
And you go under and yes,
being savage,
intelligent avenue.
Animal,
yes.
Work.
And you're going to do this.
You're going to be a ferocious animal.
You're going to fight,
puff,
put both hands to the body,
your these,
your jab,
you to do this and ferocious fashion.
And they picked all that in me.
If I was younger and you were like 1213
years old.
Wow.
So they're putting you under and just
teaching you that mindset.
Yeah.
Whoa.
Did he give you any advice on how to
shut it off?
No.
He's probably like,
I don't have any time.
Let me time.
The kid is 13.
How old is because there's no time,
no time.
I'm not going to teach them the off
switch.
Just hit the gas.
Therefore the word,
the gas destroyed,
he's got,
he's got in our way of,
you know what I mean?
Greatness.
Glory.
It's one of the hardest things that many
fighters I've,
that I've watched over the years have
the problem of shutting it off.
Like turning it on and living like that
and just wanting to be a dominator.
But then learning how to be a father.
Learning how to be
man,
my friend and my first lifetime with
children and stuff,
trying to do this stuff.
Man,
I feel filled.
The disasters,
they,
you know,
it's just,
um,
I had no idea what I was doing too.
I had no idea what it was,
what arena was stepping into.
It was just,
it was just a disaster.
I find out,
uh,
I spend most of my adult life now I'm
apologizing to my kids.
You know what I mean?
Yeah,
yeah.
I can imagine me a horrible father.
Do you think they understand the shit
that you were going through?
They understand.
Yeah.
I have no idea.
No.
I don't know.
I tried to basically make sure that part
of my life is empty now.
The different life for my kids and
family now.
Yeah.
Well that's beautiful.
It's beautiful that you,
you,
like Tom was saying earlier,
you have a lot of self reflection.
You've,
you've managed to look at your life and,
and find out what's,
what has value to you and what helps
you.
You always have to do self evaluation.
I mean,
it's a strong believer in that if
somebody has to check you,
you have to check yourself.
I agree.
Yeah.
Well,
especially a guy like you who's,
you know,
you're,
you've been checked,
your ego's checked,
your life
has been checked if it's so many down
moments as well as up moments.
You've had the,
the full ride of experiences.
Never with Avaya with my ego being
chicken and no idea that that wasn't
what it was about.
So you thought if your ego checked,
you would go and be nothing when I,
my ego.
Wow.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean it makes sense when you're going
through all that hypnosis when you're 12
and 13 years old.
But that's a crazy thing to do to a kid
because it was sand.
No idea.
But I wanted to do it so bad.
I wouldn't succeed so bad.
You could tell,
you know,
I watched a video of you a real
recently,
you were about 16,
16,
17 years old and you were sparring with
some big guy who was a professional
heavyweight and you were,
uh,
it was what was fascinating to me about,
it wasn't just watching move around when
you were young and still learning,
but it was also,
you were upset at yourself after it was
over.
You didn't think it went well.
And,
and I was like,
Oh,
remember that?
You don't remember.
It was,
it was an interesting video,
man.
You were like,
I didn't go well,
I could tell it didn't go well.
I was a thick perfectionists.
That's what I was going to say and it
seemed like it like you were obsessed as
my whole life.
That's all I did was look at Bucklin
Watch Bach,
the read about fighters and it was all
about fighting the fight of the,
my God,
Fido,
you know that kind of stuff.
Fight after I want to be around them and
be their groupie.
That's another amazing imagine that you
also knew Jim Jacobs and that's fucking
fight library.
That's watched films up to El hazing.
This is pre vhs,
right.
Beat people at Vhs,
but not many and there's fight.
Those fights were not vhs away mentally
for like if you didn't,
if you missed the fight,
you weren't going to see it again.
Right?
Yeah.
Paypal and Jim Jacobs,
he kept those things on like a regular
old projector type thing.
If you listen to the voiceover on some
of those old fights,
it's Jim Jacobs.
Yeah,
it's him doing commentary on some of the
old fights.
It didn't have any phones study.
All these guys all day and all night.
You study though.
Yeah.
He was through you.
That I learned about a lot of fighters
when you were talking about Jack Dempsey
and talk about different fighters from
the old days.
I learned about a lot of those guys from
you and went back and watched some of
those tapes and now it's beautiful.
Now you can just get on youtube and you
see whatever you want to see everything,
see all of it.
But to go back and watch my was away
from my office in precedent.
If you're going to feed this.
Yeah,
they shout exactly.
I can't wait.
I want you to come by.
Um,
cause we ran two and the ranch's I'm in,
um,
productive.
It's going to be off.
So you said 2022?
Yeah.
So,
uh,
four year.
What does it,
yeah,
four years from now,
three years from now.
We pretty awesome.
Yeah.
That's awesome.
Well,
the plans look amazing.
You know how long you guys been working
towards this a,
listen,
we have seen the property and then um,
we purchased it and we were just,
um,
we were just overwhelmed with this.
It's probably what?
I don't know.
Maybe a year ago,
maybe even that.
Maybe,
maybe a year or so.
You didn't have,
are you going to have a gym up there?
Hey,
I never thought it,
but we will have because we don't have
the wellness center.
Yeah,
Dude.
How great would it be if you taught like
a boxing class?
I know about that stuff though.
We got to hang out there and work out.
Just a fun box in class,
like hitting the heavy bag.
Just something fun.
You don't have to get people beating
each other up.
Do you know how much people would pay to
smoke weed and come where had a box from
you smoke weed.
Do you smoke weed with people?
Just regular folks.
Yeah,
it's,
look we,
yeah.
I was trying to get my wife to smoke
with me.
No,
she doesn't smoke.
She smoked only at nighttime.
She can't function during the daytime.
Oh,
right,
right.
During the day.
Well,
I would imagine if I was a mother it
would be very hard to get high because I
get paranoid.
You know?
I'd be a lot fun.
She doesn't do it during the day.
At night.
It's different.
Smoke,
a little weed,
relaxed.
How did you ever do any fighting?
I did kickboxing and how many
tournaments?
I was,
uh,
I was pretty good at taekwondo.
I won a bunch of state championships and
won a few national.
What did he do?
You know,
you wanted to get physical in another
human being and do this stuff.
Can,
you know,
you can't be in the right frame of mind
and want to do this stuff.
Got To realize that I was this stuff and
not in the right frame of mind and half
dealing with fear drives you insane.
Deal with that.
Drives people insane.
I was insane during my career.
Yes.
Madly and staying from fear.
Yeah.
Obviously I never went through anything
like the level that you went through,
but for these full contact taekwondo
fights,
I was always scared and uh,
but I was scared before that I was
bullied.
I moved around a lot.
I was a little kid.
I was never very big and we moved from
New Jersey to San Francisco when I was
seven,
from San Francisco to Florida.
When I was 11 Florida to Boston when I
was 14 or 13 so it's just always moving
a new schools always deal with new kids
and I wasn't big and I didn't know how
to fight and I got picked on and I
didn't like it.
So I said,
I wanna I want to figure out how to
fight.
And so I started getting into martial
arts and I just became obsessed with it.
I did it every day.
I started teaching.
I was teaching at Boston University is
teaching a taekwondo course.
When I was 19 I was competing from the
time I was 15 I just threw myself into
it.
It's all I did every day I worked at the
school.
I was there every day.
I had the keys,
I closed up,
I opened up where I am because of you,
because of hearing about you.
When you were running in the morning,
when you knew that everybody else was
asleep,
that gave you an edge.
I go there in the middle of the night
and open up and work out.
I just wanted to just have an edge,
you know?
And I've listened to what you said and I
said,
that's a great way to have an edge.
I became obsessed with it,
but there was no future in it.
And then what happened was I went from
taekwondo to kickboxing and when I
started kickboxing,
I started getting fucked up.
Do's are beating the shit out of me
because I was realizing like I can't
keep people at the same distance anymore
cause I didn't know how to use my hands
properly.
Like I knew how to throw some punches a
little bit from taekwondo,
but it's not nearly sophisticated as
boxing or kickboxing.
And so then I started kickboxing
training and then I started realizing
like there's no future in it.
It's like,
what am I doing?
I'm just getting my brains beat in,
you know,
and I'm hard sparring.
Two of the sparring was rough.
It was Boston style.
Put the gloves on and beat the shit out
of each other.
Figure it out as you
yeah.
Ain't going shit.
So a lot of headaches and you know,
but it was,
um,
it was hard for me to,
to shut that part of me off the part of
me,
they just wanted to conquer the part of
me just wanting to win all the time to
figure out a way to be more intense,
more driven,
more focused.
But when I did stop fighting,
it was a huge relief.
Like the relief part was worth the extra
anxiety that I got.
It was worth it just for the relief of
not,
not thinking about fighting all the
time,
not thinking about when's the next
tournament,
when's the next event?
When's the next thing I'm doing?
It was just,
wait.
Well,
for you it had to be way crazy because
not only is it the weight,
it's the heavyweight championship of the
world.
I always wanted to make my mentor happy.
Yeah.
That was my goal,
to make him happy when he died.
Was it weird not having a person like
that?
My,
and it was so,
man,
it was just emptiness.
It was just,
and then people who we go with our
friends and that we say we're going to
be good too.
They started when he died,
they started going in for the kill.
You just want to grab me for means.
Well it seemed like you and Kevin Rooney
had a good combination at the beginning
when he died,
when,
when customers,
we didn't know what we're going to do.
They're thinking about getting rid of
Kevin and said,
and I was saying I didn't want to be
with nobody else.
I was comfortable with Kevin and the
style and the way we were going.
I didn't want to be in oil.
So I said,
no,
let's just keep Kevin.
Yeah.
And Kevin was a great training for me.
Very well respected trainer.
Yeah.
It was a good relationship.
Like the way it worked in the beginning
it looked like,
but then like all things,
you know,
Kevin used to train me and then fighting
our finances and to call it.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Wow.
And this was all like,
was he training you um,
before,
before cus died as well?
Well,
yeah.
How many,
how many years before Christ died?
Was he like holding mitts for you and if
the couple,
but he knew you well?
Yes.
Did He,
well,
did he watch fights with you as well?
Did you or were you watching
watch a fight?
The monthly arm started training with
each other.
We started watching fights together
because you're stuck.
That was the other thing to your style.
The way you would come out was so
reminiscent of old fighters and when you
come out and no socks on black shoes.
Wow.
That would think in my,
my mind.
I think it was a lot about gladiator and
via telephone and how another thing now
look at enough to look at I philly
little philly kid.
Thank you.
Tough.
I would think.
I just can't thank you
where you were tough man.
I know what you're saying.
But you were when you fought Marvis
Fraser on what does the ABC,
maybe she had fight.
I remember watching that fight going,
Holy Shit.
It was like being locked into a ring
with a tornado.
That was wild day.
Yeah.
That was a tough kid.
That was your peak.
That was when it was peak.
Scary.
You know,
you were coming up and everybody was
just terrified.
It was just a wild thing to watch man.
To be a part it to be you.
Yeah.
One of the,
uh,
make my mentor happy though as my main
goal and fighting.
It's a powerful goal.
Yeah.
Did you ever try to go back and get
hypnotized after all that's over the try
to maybe calm down.
That part of your mind
turned 'em I never did.
I had to do the toll,
I think helped me out the total.
Yeah,
it definitely,
that stuff will help me out.
Did we'd help you out at all?
I'm pretty much,
yeah.
You know what I mean?
But I had to do it every day.
I had to do it all the time.
It all the time then yeah.
If I went to another country and I
didn't have my weed up at insane,
they what?
No.
We're going to be here a couple of days
a week.
A month.
Get the hell out of here.
Yeah.
The rest of the world will catch up
eventually.
They'll catch up eventually.
It's slowly happening.
We were talking about it before the show
started that just a few years ago,
if you smoked weed you,
you felt like you were a criminal.
Like you have to hide those.
I look around,
you look around.
Who's got a cop still like that in New
York?
I was in New York recently and we had a
hyde weed.
That's crazy there.
I'm like,
how is this New York City and
antiquated,
so stupid.
Just doesn't make any sense.
Especially when like we're both high
right now then man,
the kite,
it's fine.
Everything's good.
Having a nice conversation.
I totally agree.
How many fights did Jim Jacobs have in
that library?
Oh,
no.
Thousands of man.
I watch thousand guy fighting an 1890
eighth west.
The mall.
Wow.
Who were standouts for you outside of
the standard,
like obviously Jack Johnson.
Yeah,
he was awesome too.
Um,
he was just amazing.
He was ahead of his time fighting it.
Some little guys like Tony,
Kevin and Arie Hamdi,
Armstrong Barney Ross guy.
It's like that Benny Leonard,
this guy that just,
they evolve buckling through the level
where it can evolve too.
Now they became,
they were superstars in that time.
Who's that crazy middleweight who went
up to fight Jack Johnson and Charles
Stanley Catcho.
That's right.
He's a bad ad punch.
Yeah.
He's a bad ass.
Then he got killed.
Yeah.
I ain't got time.
Cause cause he stole this guy's
girlfriend and he was a tough guy.
Like what are you going to do about if
Pete,
the guy,
he'll be disrespected the guy and the
guy came back and shot him standing
kitchen with a real wild and crazy guy.
Well most of the greats were.
Yeah,
he was wild.
That's a new feel it then pay anyone.
But when you talk about like your life
and like the way you were living,
if you go back to most of the greats,
like Roberto Duran,
he was a wild mother fucker.
Beautiful.
It was beautiful with that rhythm with
it.
Yeah.
There's so many of the greats were just
wild,
wild people.
You know?
I think that that fear that is pretty
that out of you.
Yeah.
But then there was some grades that were
just real disciplined,
like struggling.
Marvin Hagler is my best example for
that.
When I was a kid growing up in Boston,
Hagler was the middle weight champion of
the world,
and I used to see,
they used to have video of him running.
They played it on the news.
He was running on the,
there was the dunes sand dunes and Cape
Cod in the winter,
freezing cold with a Hoodie on,
running,
screaming war.
Whoa.
Oh,
it was amazing.
Marvin Hagler made you want to just get
out of your house and go running in the
snow.
You know,
he was so disciplined.
That was the thing that I always got out
of watching him,
wasn't that he was so wild.
He was so mentally strong.
He had an iron chin and his discipline
was an impeccable,
his deeds.
He was just constantly training.
Never add a shape,
never got fat.
Always doing sit ups and push ups.
Some ferocious animal.
They through the body.
Yeah.
Oh,
he was chiseled.
He was a machine that fight with Tommy
hearns.
Um,
that was one of the greatest
middleweight and counters of all time
chaos.
I mean it's,
we didn't know what was going to stop
the fight.
The fight and Tommy hearing through,
they'll be,
the winner is skillful.
As they were,
they decided to just smash,
just get into the center and fucking
foot.
There was no like Tommy hearns control
to try to use his jab box in the house.
Are you going to keep it?
You're not going to keep them for your
dog.
Try to take them out of the film with
crazy.
You can't back from like they,
you know,
sugar ray Leonard did that.
They don't have,
they weren't at their prime then.
Yeah.
I wanted to see those two guys in their
prime is go at it.
Yeah.
Sugar Ray Leonard.
When especially when he fought Hagel,
he fought hygge or smart stay the fuck
away.
I heard the craziest rumor.
Tell me if this is the craziest rumor
that Marvin Hagler like decided to bet
on himself for that fight.
Didn't knew that he was going to lose.
Like they had it set up and then retired
and went to Italy
as a ridiculous rumor.
Right.
And know what anybody did.
But on the,
I never heard anything like that.
You never heard that one?
No,
but he's the more,
one of the most interesting end of
careers.
I heard a rumor that he didn't fight the
fight,
that he should have fight that and he
should have fought.
You know what I mean?
Well,
the rumor was he went to Italy because
the mob said everything.
Yeah.
Something to that effect.
He went to Italy and became a giant
movie star,
but he's the only guy that I can think
of in recent memory that literally went
out on top,
had unbelievably close fight with sugar
ray Leonard,
who a lot of people think he could have
won that fight.
Very close decision and then says,
that's it.
See Ya,
I'm done.
Everybody comes back.
Come back.
Yeah.
I guess I'm at one time.
That's your whole life.
I would think of my,
I'm for prior then never came back.
That was just my whole life.
That was my whole identity.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
But when you did retire and when you
retired in the ring,
that was the most honest retirement
speech I've ever heard of box give ever.
He's just like,
I don't,
I don't have this in medium
and once with him in the air anymore,
this is,
um,
I looked pretty bizarre for myself even,
Ya know,
cause this is what I base my life on
doing when I first started doing it.
If I'm a dedicate my life to this stuff.
Okay.
He gets to see that it's not even,
I'm no longer happened was pretty weird.
When did you know that you didn't want
to do it anymore?
I'm known years before that,
but I was still being very successful.
Yeah.
Like when like what year?
Like do you remember around when you
started thinking it?
I don't remember.
Probably man,
what?
The 2000 area.
So by the time that that's post
holyfield yeah,
after,
yeah.
Then you just get it done too much.
I was just winning them.
You see winning beating guys,
you know,
guys get hit with something and from to
be feel scared.
Yeah.
What did,
what did you have in mind?
Like that's the hardest thing,
right?
To to swing from that to the next thing.
Like how do you take,
how do you take this crazy exciting
life?
Oh No,
I thought I lifted.
Let me if get high for a while and
figured it out.
That was the plan.
Yeah.
Let me party for a while to figure this
stuff out.
What did you figure out?
Um,
uh,
I wanted to do other things.
So I started,
my wife arranged for me to be the death
being on stage that she created the
Maya.
Yeah,
that's a brilliant idea because you're
also the first fighter that ever did
that.
Cause many fighters have great stories,
but very few of them we've ever,
I don't think anybody besides you,
it was ever put into it.
And we went all over the ct do that man.
It's just amazing.
We did in Monaco,
we didn't own,
we did it,
um,
uh,
amount of various places.
And now my eighth can't believe that
people want to see this though.
Well,
like I said,
the documentary was amazing.
So people want to hear the live version
of you talking about it and to see you
live in person.
Cause the first time we did it,
the first time we did it,
I'm on Broadway dated,
right.
We were really
sure about how it's gonna turn out.
So we invited all of our friends.
We had taken the,
gave all to our friends and people we
love like names and we pulled them to
the show.
And so when we started they started
laughing.
But if I left,
I ran in my right wife,
I ran,
I still got the baby.
What's going on and listening.
Okay.
Can you I,
I didn't want the show to be a comedy.
It turned out to be a common with hard,
gritty show about a tough guy.
Right.
I made it through his toughness and he
just came up on me.
It's talking about myself,
how much his stomach I am,
you know,
and they loved it.
Well,
I think that was part of it is cause
like they all,
everybody knew you were this tough guy,
but they didn't know that you can be so
self deprecating and have so much fun
with it all.
You know?
That's what people loved it because
yeah,
they're doing the writing for my,
my moving and stuff.
I haven't seen it anywhere.
That's going to be pretty wild.
Who's playing you in a movie?
I don't know various people,
but you know most likely when Jv Brown
and Jamie,
Jamie Foxx to do it,
he could do it.
He can do anything.
He could do anything,
anything.
That guy could be the fucking president
of United States.
He could be a pilot that goes to the
moon.
He could do whatever the fuck you want.
I want him to do it.
Yeah.
He could do whatever he wants.
He'll probably bulk up like crazy too to
do it.
It's going to be really,
wow.
Yeah.
Jamie could pull it off.
Michael Jai white pulled it off.
Michael Jai white and do it like Jamie.
I Dunno.
I thought it didn't do a bag.
A lot of people didn't like what he did,
but I thought he did a good job.
You did a good job.
He,
I loved him and spawn.
He's a great guy.
Do you know him well?
No.
He's a great guy.
Great Guy.
Very smart guy.
Very humble guy.
Really,
really intelligent and a great martial
artist too.
Michael Jai White.
There's a kill Kachin a karate black
belt is bad.
The fight,
the fight in the UFC now when he was
fighting,
there was no ufc around,
but he did a lot of karate tournaments
and stuff is very good.
I've watched him train before.
He's legit.
Very legit.
But like I said,
real,
real good guy.
But yeah,
I agree.
Jamie Foxx,
man.
Jamie Foxx is on another planet.
He's just got this level of competence
and skill and artistry in his singing
and his comedy and his acting.
He could do anything.
He could play you.
He's going to hang out with you for
awhile.
I don't know what he's,
it's gotta.
It's gotta hang out with you
food pretty often.
He's got to hang out with you got to
absorb it,
right?
Yeah.
To see what,
how that without,
are you going to be good kids
consultant?
You're going to be like pitch.
I would have never said that.
I would like to say that.
Yeah.
But for some reason they get them.
They have the Hollywood wave of doing
thing.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
They make it come out of Hollywood ish
gift.
Yeah.
Cause some thing that I'm,
it's this,
this is really wild.
How did they tried to switch it to
appear?
Um,
cause Annabelle,
right?
Yeah.
They tried to change the story and no
one else I realized too when Hollywood
perspective from things,
the religious is just still
unbelievable.
Yeah.
So yeah.
So there really is unbelievable.
Yeah.
Well do you know that movie Fox Catcher?
Did you know that movie?
They had a roughly movie,
I remember that story of the young guy.
I remember that.
Yeah.
That Guy Mark Schultz.
It was Dave Schultz in March lesson.
Dave Schultz who got murdered.
Mark Schultz is the guy who fought in
the UFC.
Here's what's crazy about that movie.
I don't know how much of that movie's
accurate.
I don't know.
I wasn't there,
but what I do know is the one thing that
I for sure know happened,
they changed when he fought in the UFC.
Mark only fought in UFC wants.
He fought a guy named big daddy
goodrich.
Gary big,
big black guy were karate,
gi and then eventually got rid of the
gay later in his career,
but he's a legend.
Big Daddy's.
Imagine you didn't have it in the movie.
It's not big daddy and the movie's
fighting some white guy.
It doesn't make any sense.
They just,
they changed who he's fighting for.
No reason.
It's a historical event.
It's like if you,
for whatever reason,
they decided to not have you fight
Trevor Berbick you fought someone else
like you fought Gerry Cooney for the
title.
It's not going to be crazy.
They were like,
why would you change history?
Like I hope they don't do nothing.
I'm not going to win.
I can't want to do that.
They do something like that.
That has to be,
they did it with the UFC and when they
did it with foxcatcher can be by,
but it doesn't make it any better.
That's what's crazy.
It doesn't make the movie any better to
have him fight a Russian guy.
It doesn't make him a bed.
If I could be known right in the UFC,
especially for people like me that are
in the audience and go,
oh look,
look who's playing big daddy high.
They do a big daddy,
big daddy.
He's tough.
He took big daddy down at where they do
whatever you want it to him.
He's Mark Schultz who was a fucker of a
wrestler.
I mean him and his brother was savages.
They were savages.
They were just made out a down
the deal with they guy.
How did they hook up with that guy?
What did,
he was really daily
rich and there's no money in amateur
wrestling and these guys,
a lot of them were really struggling
when they're trying to make the Olympics
team,
I mean they're,
they're getting by barely.
They barely have enough money for
healthy food and they need sponsors and
sometimes it gets sponsors,
like a rich guy who owns a business or
you know,
he loves the Olympics,
he loves wrestling.
Maybe he wrestled in college and he'll
take care of them.
Get maybe get them some vitamins,
maybe sponsoring with the Indian,
you know,
they have various people that help them
with their training and their food.
But this guy came along and said,
look,
I'm going to build a gigantic facility
to create the best wrestling program and
pay you guys all money to come and train
here.
And they couldn't help it.
It's like they were poor.
They didn't know what to do,
but I understand that.
Yeah.
And he was a guy who is like a trust
fund guy.
He got all his money from his family and
he was just some crazy rich asshole and
he wound up shooting one of them.
Yeah,
I mean that's what it is.
I mean,
the store,
like you said,
the story itself is fucking crazy
enough.
The actual store,
they didn't have to change anything of
it.
So I know they changed that part of it.
So who knows what else in the movie the
added or changed or fucked with.
They fucked with something they didn't
have to fuck with.
They went Hollywood with it in a way
that they didn't have to do.
So it makes you,
you question all the other things that
happened in the movie and it's pretty,
so for you they can't,
you can't do that.
Your life was crazy
in thing.
I'm no way I was saying I'm with,
okay,
I really,
I really want to do this stuff,
man.
I really want to go on the screen with
my life and be fulfilled.
These people,
I think that really need that.
I,
you know,
I'm thinking about that recently.
They're really neat though and um,
candidate has been,
this is getting ready to pop off and do
really well.
I'm thinking,
I really,
I don't really,
they're really needs this money that
hurt you.
It's not going to hurt you.
It's going to help you.
Anything helps you at this point.
You're so honest that anything that
you've done in the past that you're
embarrassed about or shameful of,
it just makes,
it's just better.
It's just better for you.
It's like you made mistakes is people
can learn from them.
These are beneficial.
So watching someone like you talk about
your life is beneficial for people
because you learn how you can overcome
these experiences.
How,
how bad things can be for you.
You learn how bad you can fuck up and
people need to see shit like that.
It's good for,
it's good for civilizations,
good for our culture.
I think so at plastic guy like you who
was like I said when I was a kid,
you're the fucking man.
I mean you were the fucking man to have
a guy like you be self deprecating
explaining and laughing about things.
It makes it even,
it sinks in more.
It's like you were saying,
we were saying about custom model that
his wisdom,
it's sunk in like he was the gravel in
his voice and the intensity in his eyes
and the wisdom in his words,
it's sunk in.
I remembered his quotes for years
afterwards because he lived so much
because he had so much,
and that's the same thing with you man.
When you,
when you were talking about your life
experiences,
like people listen,
they take it in because they know you
lived an extraordinary life,
so they better not fuck this movie out
and it really extreme.
It's extreme as it gets.
What's Mark Stream other than a soldier
and those are the only people that live
a more extreme life first responder
soldiers,
firemen,
police officers.
Yeah.
That's it.
I mean they,
they're seeing death and violence every
day.
Other than them.
You probably lived the most extreme life
ever.
Who the fuck can relate to you?
Do you ever get together with other like
worldclass pro boxers that have
no,
but the guy that do get it and took it,
the guy who talked about the veteran,
the,
yeah.
Maybe telling me with the,
you know,
oh man.
Yeah.
Talked to seals about their time
deployed,
so probably they don't take themselves
out of that.
Those guys.
Yeah.
Thanks.
Well a lot of those guys are finding
some relief in the same things that you
found it.
Family farm or leave and,
and DMT and other psychedelics,
mushrooms.
I think that that could be a great
benefit to a lot of our veterans.
I believe that 100% too.
I don't know why they don't want to
dabble in this stuff.
Yeah.
What do you think would have happened to
you if you got ahold of that stuff?
While you were in your prime.
I don't know.
I don't think maybe I want to be a
fighter then.
Yeah.
Maybe I won't want to be a fighter.
Damn.
D tmt might have derailed it.
Yeah.
I might want to love everybody.
Definitely make you feel it when you
come out of it.
You got love for you.
Yeah,
buddy.
Yeah.
Well
my hope is that uh,
with great organizations like maps,
um,
that one day people will be able to see
things like everybody would be able to
see things the way you do and then we'll
all have this understanding what these
things are there.
They're tools that can help us all these
things including marijuana.
It's a tool to help us.
You going to use any tool you can abuse.
Any tool there is,
you can take a hammer and hit yourself
in the head.
If you're stupid,
you could abuse anything,
but you could also use it in a,
in a make,
build yourself a beautiful house.
And with cannabis you can,
you could use it to make it makes you a
nicer version.
Does makes you more,
I've felt more vulnerable.
Have more of a sense of community.
I'm always hugging people when I'm high.
I want to hug everybody.
You know,
I agree.
It's a better feeling.
You know what I mean?
It makes you,
it makes you feel kind.
I agree.
I like feeling.
Okay.
What is it like for you to,
uh,
to watch boxing these days?
Isn't that in my life anymore?
You don't watch it at all?
It did you watch Tyson fury?
Deontay wilder.
I was in the air flying when they were
fighting.
Oh really?
Did you didn't watch it?
The highlights or anything for some of
the highlights?
Yeah.
How crazy is deontay?
Wilder is power.
Good stuff.
Crazy rights.
Cause he's built so strange.
It's totally how incredible.
How incredible of titans.
Chore.
Incredible.
And gets up and wins the rest of the
round.
That's what's really incredible.
It's amazing.
Amazing fight.
Yeah.
So you don't follow,
you don't follow any of the tail with,
um,
you know,
that's part of my life.
Um,
I'm,
um,
I've got mixed feelings with that part
of my life.
Right.
And I stuffed up there.
I don't like about myself and stuff.
That is right.
I tried to forget that stuff cause I'm
on a whole different.
Um,
if I hadn't.
Yeah.
So even watching other people by,
I don't even what to,
nothing.
I tried to stay away much as possible.
So watching other people box makes you
think about yourself when you were
fighting reminds you of it kind of.
Yeah.
I would say these guys are so much
Nathan and I was,
you know what I mean?
I'd be the cool guy.
Yeah.
Right.
Like who,
who,
yeah.
There's no one out here today that's got
that mean,
vicious persona and Nice Guy.
Yeah.
You,
when you were in the ring doing a post
fight interview saying you want to eat
your children,
you want to eat someone's children.
I remember saying that.
This is the craziest fucking post fight
interview.
It was.
It was about Lennox Lewis,
right?
Yeah.
If I'm mad,
maybe one of the great,
what's wrong with me?
I'm just a madman.
It was amazing.
It was amazing for,
for the story,
for the time.
I mean,
look what it was was when we saw rocky
three,
right.
And Mr t was,
it was challenging,
you know,
a rocky and he would say all that crazy
shit about what he was going to do.
My prediction pain.
No.
Beautiful.
It's beautiful.
What you did is you took that and just
cranked it up to 11 and threw gasoline
on it and lit it on fire.
You just took that kind of ferocious
shit.
Yeah.
I look at some of those prep conference
in a long time.
I'm what?
I'm faintly talk to anybody like that.
That's a different world now.
My world feels different now.
Do you feel when you watched that stuff
that you feel almost like trapped by
that past like that you have to
acknowledge it.
You don't even acknowledge it anymore.
Yeah.
For that,
I'm almost a little bit like,
I don't want to be involved.
We stayed.
Never happened.
Yeah.
But kind of had to happen for you to be
who you are.
They'll know it because people,
this is the real reason that [inaudible]
people,
stihl people left that guy.
Yeah.
And then people would love that.
I didn't like that guy that much.
So I have my own conflicting with people
that like that guy and me living my life
that I am living now.
Yeah.
Well people love that guy because that
guy gave them a drug and that drug was
excitement.
Like you turn on the TV like,
Oh shit,
here we go,
Michael Spanx,
Mike Tyson.
Here we go.
And boom.
Oh,
that's what people wanted.
They wanted that excitement.
They knew some crazy shit was about to
go down.
Unpredictable.
You can't,
you don't.
No one knows it's going to happen at a
fight.
Is it going to be a right or a left?
Is he going to move right is you're
gonna move left.
How's it going to work out?
You don't know how long could spank
slas.
You don't know.
And everybody was excited and that was,
that's what you brought people.
You brought people this,
this chaotic moment.
You slapped down the money and the paper
views.
You've got at your popcorn and you
waited for the dirt rush.
The rush of excitement of the crazy
days.
Crazy days.
Okay then.
I hate to keep bringing your head back
to that,
but just for me as a kid growing up
during that time,
it was a big part of my,
you know,
my becoming an adult.
It was during your era,
you're
ever of dominance.
How we'd look at my kids and I think,
why did you guys,
uh,
pretty much,
um,
middle class kid,
they live their life to do what they
wanted to go to college and everything.
I W I w I would never want to put that
pressure on my son.
That you have to be the total best.
You have to dominate everybody.
You're going to be the best that ever
live at this.
He's put that kind of pressure on him.
That's incredible.
Would never do that to them.
Yeah.
It would never work.
Probably.
I mean,
I don't think a kid that grows up in a
loving household would supportive boxing
for when you have nothing to boxing.
When you did it had nothing.
Cause that's a lot of,
um,
a lot of dedication.
It's a lot of pain.
That's a lot of aggravation.
Louder.
You know what I mean?
Really?
Yes.
I'm discovering who you are,
but you must be able to take pride in
the fact that your children don't ever
have to do that.
Oh,
and that's why I took the punches for,
they wouldn't have to do now.
I had my first might have to send a 16.
He wanted to be
box of it.
I saw you working with
private school boxing,
[inaudible] European trips.
He did trips and us to vacation.
You have to be a fight and kid how to
hear the joke.
And he's really soon.
I think he's serious,
man.
I know a nobody.
He lived to good fight.
Some guy like me from animal can't know
when my kids go through that crap.
That's the degrading from guy like that
beating on you.
Yeah.
That's the thing is the fuel that you
had,
the,
the burning and ferno inside you,
you can't replicate that.
They don't understand that.
They don't,
I don't know.
You know,
a lot of stuff.
Um,
in spite shaming inspires a lot of
success.
Yeah.
You know,
they don't have to deal with that kind
of shame.
Right,
right.
Shame,
pain.
Exactly.
Feeling of being left out,
feeling of not belonging,
and you gotta write to this.
I'm going to be,
everybody's going to love me.
Crazy feeling.
It's Felix mentioned to get people
because you wouldn't be accepted so
badly.
Yeah.
Imagine that it fully accepted people
that look at you,
you know and know what kind of mindset
of that,
that that either want people to just
look at you.
Yeah,
you're a sick fuck.
Want me to look at me?
Look,
oh mom,
man.
Yeah,
but it's beautiful that you could
describe it that way now.
Like you've stepped outside of it long
enough.
Do you recognize what it was when it was
overcoming that?
I used to be stories.
Alexander the great had this guy was a
god.
Wow,
I want to be like that.
You know?
This is crazy.
It's just crazy that you can inspire
them,
that you're more than what you are.
What was also those feelings of
conquering?
We're giving you the first success in
good feelings of your life and the fact
that they programmed you.
I mean,
that's something that I don't think a
lot of people are aware of.
The,
the,
the hypnotism to hypnotism and the
putting those thoughts into your mind,
which were hugely beneficial that you
could tap into that mind zone right
before you competed and they may need,
they gave you a clear path.
They give you a clear path to use your
fury with this like very analytical
approach with perfect boxing technique
and an amazing mentor with incredible
amount of knowledge.
And they just let you loose to the
ethic.
Have to do the math.
Yeah.
Bad intention.
Being bad intention and having through
the,
and when you're fighting and loving
every minute of it.
Yeah.
Look at you.
You getting fired up again.
Do you work out anymore?
Nah,
man.
Keep away from that stuff and they don't
even like a,
all that stuff,
you know,
spin class or anything.
No.
All that stuff.
Um,
and reactivate to my ego.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Oh Wow.
Don't they get ripped on us today?
We activate it.
That's the thing about like extreme
winters,
extreme winters that,
that that ego is hard.
My Ego.
I'm a lose lose.
I'm losing this candidate.
I'm gonna lose everything.
What have you let go jogging.
Can you go jogging?
Nah,
I can't do it.
Do My treadmill working stone treadmill.
That's it.
But if I thought the thing that I'm
specialist,
I get a glimpse,
a glimmer of that thing for,
hey,
whoa.
Yeah.
Get you you better than though.
I saw a video.
You're hitting the back recently.
It was like a couple of years ago,
you still had the bag.
He still throw some bombs partly for the
camera.
Yeah,
that's what you are doing it.
But I'm like,
damn,
you can still move.
You still have it in you,
right?
I don't know.
It's in your body.
Have to be,
I don't want nothing to do,
but what I was going to get to when if
you were standing front of that heavy
bag and you start rattling off
combinations and people,
you start thinking like,
Oh shit,
I'm actually Mike Tyson.
Like I was that guy.
I am that guy who went through that.
I am the youngest heavyweight champion
of all time.
I am that guy to destroy tyrrell bigs.
I am that guy that knocked out Larry
Holmes.
I'm that guy,
looked at my eyes,
can look at that guy.
I look at,
that guy has given me a platform to help
me forget about that guy.
Wow.
Yeah.
It's,
it's beautiful that you have that,
that mindset.
It is because most people who've
accomplished as much as you have,
they don't want to ever let the past go.
Shit,
let that go,
let it go,
but do you,
do you recognize that,
that that's a beautiful part of your
personality.
You had one of the most successful
boxing careers ever,
but you don't want it.
You don't want nothing to do with it.
You didn't want to.
We want to acknowledge it exists.
You wish it went away in order to
arrive to that next chapter in life.
You have to forget chapter that came
before you and focusing on the chapter
ahead of you.
Yes.
That's a great lesson and from coming
from you,
that lesson I think is going to hit home
with a lot of people think though.
Yes,
a hundred percent a hundred percent
because you accomplished so much because
you were the youngest heavyweight
champion of all time because you're the
baddest man on the planet.
There's big hero for a lot of people
like me.
When I was growing up to see you now say
that's then
I'm done.
Oh,
nothing.
I don't to watch it.
I don't work out.
I'm not,
I'm not even a part of that anymore.
I'm concentrating them on live right now
and I'm happy and I love it.
People,
you know Joe,
that's really crazy,
but when you think about this,
listen,
you know,
being that person,
that guy that sent me the psych ward a
couple of times,
they send me to so many other places to
prison and they said,
why I send me places.
That guy is a trip.
That's a trick.
I had you in the underwear holding the
tiger on the change the trip.
What did you go to the psych ward for?
It's freaking crazy.
Violent.
Probably thought about hurting myself or
something crazy like that.
What do they do when they take you in
the psych ward?
How do they treat you?
Um,
no,
he's the same way.
Everybody treat me.
This is Mike.
No,
but I mean how do they take care of you?
What did they do for you?
I mean,
how do they take Mike Tyson common down
fucking pills.
The something zone you out be like,
cause I'm leaving and found me swag of
it.
Yeah.
That is what they do.
Huh?
Yeah.
Just call me down medically.
Pharmaceutically instead Zombie like if
I'm going to look at,
I told him,
you don't know what's going on.
Well you know what's going on with you
can react to it.
Jesus.
And then once the got you calmed down
enough to go,
all right,
you can go.
I don't know.
I don't think I ever get calmed down
enough.
It was time for me to go and I had to
go,
what is a day in the life of Mike Tyson
like now?
And like what does a typical day get up
in the morning?
I go to my office and my candidate for
office,
we do deals and we get investments and
um,
I'd come home at five o'clock and I go
see my kids to live 50 at the office
later and I come home and I hang out
with my wife and my kids if the,
um,
it really bizarre life.
We stay in Newport beach now.
Oh that's not really,
um,
it's very scale is very upscale,
but it's very quiet and not like Las
Vegas at all.
No one.
Then my daughter plays tennis up there,
so we're pretty much,
I'm situated up there.
Not like I said,
baby,
we can't,
we move to Hollywood.
She didn't know we can't go to beverly
hills.
No.
Cause the tennis hall of her Tennis
Requirement for here in Newport beach.
So we stay here.
Newports nice though.
It's a good place.
It's near the ocean.
It's got clean was here.
It's um,
it's,
it's just different for me.
I bet.
Yeah.
Did you like living in Vegas though?
Cause a fight today gets,
it was always crazy and everything.
The fight did bring great parties
though.
You call,
we get some great parties.
Great.
So you've settled into this business
life,
it seems like pretty easily.
Like you,
you seem to be enjoying yourself.
Hey fender,
I want to do and um,
if I'm,
if this is a fresh start,
you know what I mean?
I look,
um,
since doing the total,
you know what I mean?
My main objective and everything I'd
been embarking on and being,
um,
involving myself with,
it's all been kind of a fresh start.
I feel fresh,
it feels new and I feel that nothing can
stop in that and could be in my way and
it's just awesome feeling.
So this is from doing that one dmt
experience just sent you until I did one
time,
but I did it many,
many times that,
that right.
You know?
Yeah.
This is really,
um,
I don't know what it is.
I'm trying to figure it out,
but I've changed.
But you're still figuring out,
I still know how.
Yeah,
I describe it for a lot of people.
It's like resetting a computer and you
reset a computer.
You have a fresh new desktop and there's
only one folder on the desktop and that
folder says,
my old bullshit.
This is Lithonia stop and saying,
do my third way.
Now sometimes I'm wondering this new
feeling that I'm possessing right now,
if it,
I'm a real feeling this stuff really
help I am I lying to myself again till
the next moment,
the neck feeling come to do some drills
to be with somebody else and what's
really going on.
Has that feeling going to come back
there this moment they feel,
feel like it never coming back
it.
It can never come back if you decide
that it's never coming back,
but you have to make that decision
pretty much every day,
but you can,
you can never come back if you want or
you could slip into the old ways.
That's what a lot of people do.
One of the,
when a lot of people fall into drug
additions,
relapsing,
when they relapse,
they're not physically addicted.
When they're relapsed,
obviously they're clean and then he
decided to go back in.
It's cause there's comfort in those old
patterns because this new way of life is
just,
they get anxiety.
They feel like it's a lot of pressure to
stay clean.
Well,
that's explained it.
I hate that.
I always hated that.
Oh wait,
I never wanted to do,
but then I do him again.
I never wanted,
I hate a thousand now.
No,
no.
Come on.
You understand what I'm saying?
No,
I don't want to fuck.
I don't want that.
And then once you do that and once you
do it,
then he's going all out.
Now you haven't gone to liquor there.
The girl,
Oh man,
this is just a dark,
dark,
vicious cycle.
It's real dark.
It's self destructive.
It's all about ego inflating and self
deprecating to stroke.
It also alleviates you from the
responsibility of improving the hundred
percent that pressure of like keeping it
together,
staying sober,
being disciplined,
all that stuff.
Once it's gone,
it's gone.
Like Ah,
I'm just fucking crazy.
I'm crazy.
This is just what I do.
And it's easy to fall into that trap.
And that's what happens to a lot of
people who relapse with drugs.
I never want to go back to that again.
It's just a no win situation.
That's one of the great things about
marijuana that people don't understand.
They think that a drug is a drug as a
drug.
They're all falling under the same
category,
but you can use marijuana and just be
peaceful and not chaotic and the
opposite of make you think more about
what the consequences of ruining your
life
because they sound ridiculous.
I got um,
I got a foot in a way.
Detroit,
Michigan,
one time a for Andrew Colada.
I got 'em and tested and tested for
marijuana and they charged me 300,000
hours.
Jesus Christ find me $200,000.
That's a lot of my,
where'd that money go?
Who took it?
The commission get,
yeah,
when did coke with it?
Yeah.
That's what they did.
That's crazy.
$300,000 for some weed in your system.
Now you're selling it legally.
Yeah.
Miss,
I'm just,
this is just a bizarre situation.
I'm just going with this bizarre world
and see what happens.
It's beautiful,
man.
Never thought you could do the sell
marijuana without being in that
business.
I know at this stage in my life,
when it came at the right particular
time,
I saw it online.
I saw Tyson ranch online and saw
something on instagram or something and
I was like,
that makes sense.
Yeah.
Why not,
man?
In this day and age,
we look,
everybody loves you.
Why not?
Why not go into business and never
dreamt it?
But it's just a no brainer.
People gonna want to buy your weed just
because they love you.
I want to distribute all over the world
too.
That's where it gets sketchy.
Yeah.
There's some spots in Asia.
You don't want to bring weed to know
Singapore.
You can get killed.
I,
oh yeah,
no,
but that's the,
there's some parts of the world that
the,
if they checked it,
yeah,
like I went to Europe to buy weed
before.
I mean,
and it with 'em they were throwing in
the plant.
They weren't fell into,
but there was some of the plant you have
to buy the plant went to the plant and
make bud.
Wow.
Selling the plan.
What's that purpose?
They want you to grow your own.
Yeah,
it does.
The only way.
So you're working with a bunch of
different growers.
Explain how you guys are setting it up.
The whole thing we are working with as a
growth,
but my main objective is to be
distributed all over the country,
so to and also the ranch where you
didn't have like a,
a destination that's going to be,
that could be our resort there and
that's where people can come and go be.
Um,
it's going to be like,
um,
what's that big concert name?
Going to have our own concerts,
ditch and tell her I flipped the name of
Coachella.
Chela Chela Chela because it's going to
be something to that effect.
Yeah.
Oh,
that's awesome.
So you're going to do shows down there
too?
Absolutely.
Yeah.
We're going to do it.
[inaudible] Gamma Governor will be our
first show when Miguel is going to be
our first show in February.
Oh Wow.
Oh,
that's amazing.
That's beautiful.
But listen,
man,
I'm,
I'm very happy for you.
I'm happy.
I'm happy to see this.
I'm happy to see this transitioning.
You,
I'm happy to hear about your experiences
and,
uh,
good luck man.
That's need to come back.
Cause I'm going to be presenting at the,
um,
the podcast award.
Oh,
I high.
Yeah.
That's coming up soon.
It's going to be there.
No,
I'm not gonna know who I'm going on one.
Is that please the hell out of me?
They'll tell me.
Yeah.
They,
I think,
do you know when that is Jeremy?
Somebody sent it to me.
I'm busy that night,
unfortunately.
Yeah.
Um,
so you have a podcast to tell people
about that.
Yeah.
Go hotboxing.
Hotboxing yeah,
get it.
Yeah.
Big Top box.
We'd get it.
Boxing.
Exactly.
Yeah.
And we smoke on like,
um,
on a show and we having a good time.
Yeah.
And you,
uh,
you had dale earnhardt jr on.
Yeah.
He's an awesome guy.
He's a great guy.
He thought so.
Did you get high with them?
I know.
No,
I don't believe I did.
I don't think he'd smoke.
No,
I don't think he does either.
But uh,
if a clean cut guy,
super nice guy,
almost too nice.
Like are you real farther?
The tough guy.
Yeah.
His father was a savage.
Um,
so tell people,
uh,
Tyson branch,
tell people how they can find more
information.
When you get to look up tie thing,
rant.
Just it's a,
is it Tyson?
ranch.com?
Yup.
Okay.
Tyson,
branch.com.
And you don't fuck with any social media
hunt.
You don't mess up though.
So I had people do that,
but they tell him to take picture of
this guy for you.
Get from like
third grade friends,
friends.
I know that.
Hell,
I'm glad I put like a smoke man.
It is ridiculous.
Yeah.
Tyson ranch official on instagram and
I'm on the book,
Dope magazine.
Go Damn.
Uh,
well listen brother,
thank you very much for being here man.
I really appreciate it.
Talk show so much earlier but couldn't
make it happen again.
We'll do it again and uh,
let me know when everything opens up.
We'll be happy to promote it for you and
let everybody know.
And anytime you got something coming on,
do you want people to know about it?
Let me know.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
I appreciate it,
brother.
Thank you very much,
Mike Tyson mother fuckers.
Oh,
a day.